thanks I'm so excited to be here this
Gregg character it's it's a it's a huge
success and especially amongst the young
readers right it's been a big surprise
to me you know when I meet kids from
Sweden we don't speak the same language
but we really share the language of
childhood you know so we make a
connection that way through these
stories and that's really exciting to me
just describe who is this character Greg
Heffley is a middle school weakling he's
not in control of his life and he's not
very heroic you know I wasn't I wasn't
very heroic as a kid so it's it's fun to
have a character that's full of flaws
and that a kid can see some aspects of
themselves and Greg so this is the
opposite of a superhero in a way I think
so
you know when I was writing these books
I was actually reading Harry Potter and
Harry Potter is brave he's famous he's
rich right and I wasn't any of those
things when I was a kid I was really
ordinary so I wanted to create a
character that was imperfect like I was
are the stories also based on your
stories or is it true stories or is it
yeah a lot of the stories in the books
are embarrassingly true this used to be
my most embarrassing memory but now it's
become you know fodder for my books is
that I was on the swim team as a kid and
I used to hide out from my coach in in
the locker room in the bathroom and I'd
hide in a stall but I get so cold in
there that I'd wrap myself in toilet
paper to stay warm so I think that's
where Greg Heffley was born in that tell
me it's it's called a Wimpy Kid yeah
which III interpret us being a kind of a
coward yeah I think that it's it means
somebody who doesn't have much power a
weakling yeah it's funny there are all
over the world there are Wimpy Kid books
and there are only three countries that
I know of that don't have a word for
Wimpy and Sweden is one of them so well
but it's like this this this is a I
don't know many people having great
memories from this part of you know
childhood when you're 1213 that that age
is not a bit a good time in life is I
think it's true you know I I remember
going into middle school and there were
kids literally twice the size and yeah
and they had facial hair and pimples and
I was like I was really underdeveloped
and I think that you know a lot of
comedy is taking something taking pain
and putting it through a filter and then
it comes out as comedy so that's where
some of the best comedy comes from well
how are you as a in that age I think I
was I looked like chubby pakistanian boy
until I was maybe 15 yeah so I don't
remember I were you were you have very
happy with that wasn't a good time in
life no it's not a good time
no it's never a good time is it no I
don't know I don't I don't know because
I read about Greg that he is probably
you as well well you were in a hurry to
grow up yeah I think that's that's
something that's common to all kids
because you you feel like you want to
get to that next age level because it
means more freedom or maybe you get a
cellphone or you can stay up later but I
think childhood is a really good deal
and I wish more kids could kind of relax
and enjoy it you know enjoy their
childhoods did you enjoy your childhood
or were you in a hurry growing up no but
I've read your books
oh yeah well sort of our song has really
to be to be precise and and I mean it's
it's a nice book because you can
recognize yourself to some extent did it
its
finally ordinary it's false it's
mistakes it's those sorts of things that
I think all kids go through that's I
guess why it's so popular because people
recognize themselves in as an artist and
an author when did you discover your
talent I don't have much of a talent for
it actually I I couldn't break into the
comics business because my illustrations
aren't professional grade so what I have
what do you mean you didn't know I tried
for about three years to try and break
into newspapers that was my big dream
and I realized I didn't have the skills
I could see it on the page I didn't have
the skills to break in so what I had to
do was say I have to take away
newspapers I have to remove this thing
that I want and instead try to put my
comics into books and pretend that I'm a
kid so that nobody can criticize my my
drawings or say that they're not
professional so that's how Greg Heffley
happened when you couldn't make drawings
as looking like a grownup stories right
you just imitated the kids right yes
exactly it's sort of like an enhanced
kids drawing but it's what it's what
allowed me to break through and nobody
ever said hey this guy can't draw you
know I'm not and now you sold like a
hundred million books yeah it's a lot
it's a lot more than I should have
brought pinch pinch your arm every mic
in and we're looking you know I can't
believe I'm here right now well you are
i I think but do you do you do you make
pants how to use your money I mean you
must be a rich man you know we have more
than we need and so what we do is we try
to share it we live in a small town
that's got a really rundown downtown and
so we're trying to we've we took away a
really old building in the center and
we're building a you know a nice like a
Cultural Center that will also be a
bookstore and opening a small bookstore
in the United States is a little bit
insane but I think it's it's so
important for kids to have a physical
book in their hands you know I think
it's a bad idea for kids to do all their
reading on the screen and when you have
a physical book in your hands
you can make a connection you know your
kid makes a connection to the words on
the page and to the ideas and to the
stories so we're gonna play our part you
know a small part in trying to make sure
books are put into the hands of kids by
opening a book start by opening a
bookstore yes thank you very much thank
you so much thank you so much
first when did you find it hard to
forgive